tonight also medical care for travelers
heading in and out of mccarran airport
umc express clinic is now open victoria
saha tells us what that facility offers
three two two one
airport is now ready to help your
medical needs on site their umc express
clinic serves as an urgent care for
travelers coming in and out of las vegas
ceo mason van holling says it's for
airport staff as well whether they have
an injury we're able to do work comp
here we have x-ray capability located on
the second level of terminal one you can
see a doctor anytime between 8 am and 8
pm and according to rosemary vasiliades
director of aviation for mccarran you
can get a prescription too sometimes
passengers forget their meds as
guidelines for coven 19 testing for
international travel continues to change
you can now head from the las vegas
strip straight to the airport to get
your rapid pcr test right before your
flight it was very convenient david
hamilton was one of the first patients
for the express clinic i had taken a
test on tuesday night it's
thursday now
the test results didn't come back
so
i had to take an emergency test and as
the pandemic continues to shift the
clinic is ready for any changes so that
won't be a deterrent for our passengers
to come to las vegas
victoria saha live local now
an appointment is recommended to use the
clinic if you are looking to get tested
for covet it can take upwards of two
hours